-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now we're gonna
get to the news.
President Biden met today with
members of his administration
to discuss lowering
consumer prices
and also making sure both teams
get the ball in overtime.
[ Laughter ]
A federal judge in Texas
ruled on Friday
that President Biden could not
require federal workers
to receive
the coronavirus vaccine.
Wow. Nobody's letting Biden
get anything done.
At this point,
I wouldn't be surprised
if Wordle was only
giving him two rows.
[ Laughter ]
After the voting-rights bills
failed to pass last week,
White House press secretary
Jen Psaki
advised people who were upset
to go to a kickboxing class
or have a margarita,
because what better way
to save democracy than
with fun ideas for first dates?
"They're stripping away
our rights, one by one!
Let's paint mugs!"
[ Laughter ]
According to a new report,
Britain's Prince Andrew
had a collection
of more than 70 teddy bears,
and staff members were ordered
to arrange them
according to a diagram,
and then they could get to work
on his enormous collection
of giant red flags.
[ Laughter ]
The NFL reportedly notified
unvaccinated players last week
that they will no longer be
required to be tested daily
for the coronavirus.
In fact, some of them don't even
have to come to work.
[ Laughter ]
A television reporter
in West Virginia
who was hit by a car during
a live broadcast last week
got up uninjured and said,
"That's live TV for you."
Okay, as someone who's done
a lot of live TV,
no, it's not!
[ Laughter ]
Ashlee Simpson lip-synching --
that's live TV for you.
You got hit by a car!
"oh, my God.
Should we exchange info?"
"No, no, it's fine.
This is live TV."
Rapper Jay-Z has reportedly
signed on to a letter
urging New York
Governor Kathy Hochul
and state lawmakers
to ban prosecutors
from using rap lyrics
as evidence
against defendants in court,
not because it's unfair,
just because it's so cringey
to hear lawyers recite them.
[ Laughter ]
Singer Adele last week postponed
her Las Vegas residency
less than 24 hours
before the first show.
Fortunately, Adele fans
are well equipped
to deal with sudden heartbreak.
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
according to the latest numbers,
New Yorkers placed
more than $600 million in bets
during the first week
of mobile sports gambling,
all against the Knicks.
And that was the monologue,
everybody.